hey guys it's justine and today's video
is going to be so much fun a huge thank
you to best buy for sponsoring this
video my sister and i are actually in
hawaii right now and while we've been
here one of my favorite android phones
has been released this is the samsung
galaxy z flip three 5g and i have loved
the samsung flip lineup so i'm so
excited to really get a chance to test
this out in such a beautiful location a
huge shout out to best buy again for
partnering with me on this video they
are always my go-to for all the latest
and greatest tech and if you guys want
to get more information about the
samsung galaxy z flip 3 5g and best buy
i'll put a link in the description but
now we are going to take this thing out
on an adventure i've already shot some
sample footage when i was testing this
out originally when i did my first
unboxing so i can't wait to take this
out and test it even further
we gotta pack up jen we gotta pack up
[Music]
do you think i bring this i'm gonna
bring this
i'm gonna do a little boogie in on this
board
we do have the latest ipxh
on these devices you want one no you're
gonna boogie
[Music]
it's great i just set the flip down just
like this so i can use it as a tripod to
get this shot putting stuff in the car
she told me not to bring the boards
we're bringing the boards
first stop on our journey we're gonna
get lunch
i think we might be doing a food tour of
the island at this point on the north
shore we plan on going hiking but now
we've just eaten and now we're getting
shave ice from the place that is
supposedly the best shave ice on the
island so let's go get some pictures of
that
oh wow
thank you
[Applause]
i've been having so much fun testing
this phone out and i think one of the
things that i love so much is actually
being able to have this in my hands and
be able to see how incredible the screen
looks and one of the things that i've
seen repeatedly come up is people
talking about the crease now this is
crazy because in this video like you can
see it when you're actually using this
like in person it's there but it's also
not there and i think in videos and
photos it is more prominent for whatever
reason but honestly like i hardly even
notice that it's there i mean you're
folding a phone like come on like what
it's so cool one of the things i love
about best buy is obviously it is my
number one go-to place whenever i need
to get anything tech wise even here on
the island like there are best buys here
and if they don't have it in store it is
something that i can also get online and
what i do love about the in-store
experience especially going back to this
samsung z-flip 3 is seeing this phone in
person and really experiencing it and
actually folding it and flipping it and
seeing how beautiful this display is
it's just something that you really need
to see to really understand how cool it
is like i can sit here and tell you all
day like how awesome the screen looks
and that's why i think actually going
and seeing it because this is something
that i feel like you really need to
experience firsthand another cool thing
about best buy is they do have all of
their knowledgeable blue shirts who are
there to help so if you have any
questions about this device or anything
in general they are there to help you
with their knowledgeable customer
service i really like the portrait mode
video so this was kind of interesting
because i tried this out at a waterfall
and my hair was all over the place i was
really surprised how well it actually
did blurring out the backgrounds but yet
keeping me in focus looking at my photos
i'm just kind of scrolling through and
everything looks so crisp and clear and
vibrant
[Music]
i also filmed this little time lapse and
to get this shot i didn't have a tripod
or anything so i just
folded my phone just like this and i set
it on its side and that's what i used to
get this shot i'm actually very
impressed with how well the portrait
mode does on this but this just shows
you how well it did at identifying me in
the background and making sure i'm in
focus and the background is not i also
love how quick and easy this is to
capture content like i could just pull
this out of my pocket double click the
power button and that'll automatically
bring up this front facing camera so
with this i can tap to take a photo i
can swipe and this will switch it into
video mode so i can instantly start
recording and not even have to open my
phone up at all and i'd love this
because it's not invasive it's actually
kind of nice to hold this just like this
and not have to completely open the
phone like look at that
it's really cool so for some of the tech
specs for those of you who may be
curious this is a 6.7 inch infiniti flex
full hd plus dynamic amoled 2x display
the cover is a 1.9 inch super amoled
display this has 8 gigs of ram and you
can configure it to either 128 or 256
gigs and it has a 3 300 milliamp hour
battery this also has a 120 hertz
display which looks incredible when
you're scrolling watching content or
even playing games the front camera is a
10 megapixel and these rear cameras are
12 megapixel wide and ultra wide
[Music]
we're doing this trail we've never done
before it's a botanical garden which i
thought would be so perfect to get some
cool photos of some flowers and some
trees in the nature look at this tree
it's so cool
[Music]
is this what is it
a part of the mulberry family this is a
very very whoa very cool tree
do you think this is fungus or like um
this is like tree uh
disease actually i don't know pretty
sure that's tree disease you think yeah
so this is director's view so i can
choose how i would uh like to direct
this feature with with my little picture
and picture hi jen hello
so do we like look at this tree we'll
get up real close check that out let's
see far away
nice it's pretty cool
nice
this is great
[Music]
oh man all right so i'm back from my
adventure with the samsung galaxy z flip
3 this thing has been so much fun to
test out and right now i'm actually
using the video tracking feature to end
this video and this feature is so
awesome look at me i'm moving around
with the ultra my camera when i'm
recording in the video it's able to keep
me in view
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching i hope that you enjoyed this
video one of the other things that i was
actually very surprised about is the
durability of this because this one i
feel like they definitely stepped it up
having it be water resistant has made
such a huge difference obviously being
here in hawaii again this is a phone
that you really have to just go and feel
and see for yourself and see how awesome
it is i know a lot of other reviewers
kind of had that same sentiment because
it really is an experience checking this
out so if you guys do get a chance check
out your local best buy and go in and
check out this phone and let me know
what you guys think well thank you guys
again for watching and i'll put a link
in the description if you want more
information about best buy in the
samsung galaxy zflub35g i had so much
fun reviewing this and i can't wait to
continue on making some fun content with
it see you guys in the next video bye
my